khloe kardashian comes to kylie jenner
and travis scott's defense kylie and
travis have been keeping a low profile
since the rapper's tragic astral world
festival incident in november which left
10 concert goers dead and hundreds of
others injured
in the wake of the tragedy the couple
reportedly agreed to scrap a w magazine
cover shoot but for now part of their
interview and some of the images appear
to have leaked online
because it's a leak we won't be showing
you but the pictures show kylie travis
and their three-year-old daughter stormi
webster posing together as a family
and one tick tock user shared an excerpt
from the alleged copy reading quote
travis and kylie seemed very comfortable
under the sheets but even though they
will soon have two children together
they are not a couple and haven't been
for two years one of the tick tock
commenters claimed their friend worked
on the magazine shoot and alleged the
kylie cosmetics founder and the grammy
winner didn't speak to each other the
whole time well coco wasn't feeling that
and slid into the comments of the post
to add quote wow i don't know why this
magazine would write this but they are
very much a couple et has reached out to
w for comment
of course this is a complicated time for
the couple who is currently expecting
their second child together following
the november astroworld tragedy a 2
billion lawsuit was filed on behalf of
the 280 victims of the fatal event and
another 120 victims have contacted the
lawyers who filed the suit seeking
representation for their injuries and
damages
he calls his fans ragers and there were
moments when he would say you know who's
ready to rage who's you know where my
rangers at yeah he did that repeatedly
through the show as he's done in the
past you know and i think the crowd
responds to him very
passionately you know when he tells them
to jump up and down you feel the ground
shake the lawsuit claims that the
fatalities and injuries were quote due
to negligence carelessness and
recklessness of the defendants their
agents servants and employees in the
ownership management maintenance
operation supervision and the control of
the subject premises
it was festival seating standing room
environment sold that way that is the
most dangerous crowd configuration in in
festivals and concert in environments
because it makes people compete against
each other
for limited spaces which are like the
prime space in front of the mic of the
lead singer everybody has a right to be
there so you have competition following
the incident kylie released a statement
on instagram writing that she and travis
were quote broken and devastated adding
my thoughts and prayers are with all who
lost their lives were injured or
affected in any way by yesterday's
events and also for travis who i know
cares deeply for his fans and the
houston community
i just want to send out prayers to the
to the ones that was lost i could just
never imagine the severity of the
situation
travis also spoke out on his insta story
you know my fans my fans like my fans
really mean the world to me i just want
to send out prayers to the
to the ones that was lost last night
we're actually working right now
to identify the families
so we can help assist them through this
tough time